le 3 mars sarah evrard cadre de 33 ans
est porté disparu alors qu'elle rentrait
chez elle à brixton depuis le quartier
de clapham dans le sud de londres
son corps est retrouvé quelques jours
plus tard dans un bois au sud est de la
capitale
mis en cause un agent de la police
londonienne
wine kosinski est arrêtée vendredi soir
un agent de police en service a été
inculpé ce soir pour l'enlèvement et le
meurtre de sarah evrard d' wang zhen ses
48 ans a été placé en détention
provisoire et comparaîtra devant le
tribunal de westminster demain matin dès
le lendemain
la colère gronde plusieurs femmes se
rassemblent pour une veillée en hommage
à sarah evrard d' en dépit des
restrictions sanitaires
la mobilisation se mue en confrontation
avec la police
les forces de l'ordre menottes certaines
participantes
c'est alors un sentiment d'écoeurement
qui se propage dans la capitale
la ministre de l'intérieur priti patel
et le maire travailliste de londres
sadik-khan existe alors des explications
de la part de la police sur sa gestion
de l'événement j'ai déjà dit que
certaines des images de kla femmes
common qui circulent en ligne sont
choquantes
alors bien que la police doit
légitimement dépendantes sur le plan
opérationnel
j'ai demandé à la metropolitan police un
rapport sur ce qui s'était passé
la commissaire adjointe hélène belle de
son côté défend l'action des forces de
l'ordre assurant que la situation était
telle que son intervention était
nécessaire mais dès lors la confiance
est rompue
de son côté le leader des libéraux
démocrates appellent la cheffe de la
police a démissionné les rassemblements
pour dénoncer l'action des forces de
l'ordre et les violences faites aux
femmes se multiplient
je veux qu'elles aient les mêmes droits
que n'importe qui d'autre qu'elle se
sente en sécurité quand elles marchent
dans la rue qu'elle n'ait pas à se
demander si elle doit ou non emprunté
une rue en particulier
je ne veux pas de ça pour mes enfants ni
pour ceux des autres en parallèle de ces
événements une loi prévoyant de
renforcer les pouvoirs de la police et
présenté cette semaine au parlement un
débat qui ne devrait pas contribuer à
apaiser la situation